So one of the key aspects of
Quicksilver implementation is Log Maintenance. The transaction managers
write the log records for recovering the
persistent state. They're written in the log records
that are in memory data structure of
the transaction manager, and every so often, the
transaction managers do a Log Force. Of the
in memory log segment to the storage, for
persistence. And the frequency of log force impacts
performance, of course, because they are synchronous I/O operations.
And log force can also be initiated by
an application if it is concerned about about its
persistent state. Getting onto storage but in Quicksilver
an app has to be very careful about often
they do a log for us. Because log maintenance
is done by the transaction manager at a site,
for all of the processes that are running at that node. And so the large record
in Quicksilver actually contains all the modifications to
persistent state. Required by all the processes that
are running at this node. And therefore, if
an individual client at a node decides to
do a log force, it is actually impacting
the performance of not only that particular client,
but all the other clients as well. Therefore, services have to be very careful
about choosing the mechanisms That is available
in operating systems. Commensurate with their recovery requirments.